if Donald Trump went upright let me talk
about what would happen in Republican
today and here I have Peter Schiff
mirroring what the whistleblower was
going to say abut for them I'd Twitter
even though there was no first-hand
knowledge they would say can you believe
this president is lying he's been
removed from office
only he'd be telling the truth so let's
focus on Adam Schiff he's in the news
for his involvement with this scandal
now here's the thing it turns out for
people who don't know that the chief
knew about the whistleblower complaint
before it was filed and his team
actually advised the whistleblower on
how to proceed and president Trump this
is why he's just the best president I
mean I don't mean he's kind of better
like if you put him like okay we're
gonna rank him above like misses we
don't matter no no George Washington is
a distant second he was asked about it
responded like this at a press
conference yesterday there is a report
that came out just before you and
president Initiative walked out here
that the whistleblower met with it shows
that question Thank You Jay favorite I
mean not so here's like Trump President
Trump is right
not only did shift secretly communicate
with the whistleblower he lied about it
which brings us to this week's what a
piece of [ __ ]
took Howard to change it over to [ __ ]
that's crazy
oh it's a whole paradigm shift it's not
a super long clip but I think it
provides context not only did he
communicate he lied about the
whistleblower and communicating with him
we have not spoken directly with the
whistleblower we would like to really
really mm-hmm
that's interesting guess it's more of a
glans penis at that point to pretend
with a mouse or the Clydesdale has a
mane so by the way here's something
important to note this is the more you
unpeel the layers to this onion the more
enraged you will you will find yourself
yeah he was mirroring actually the
whistleblowers talking points on Twitter
over a month ago
to give a false sense of corroboration
right because people see it and go a
horse like well this sounds like what
this sounds like what that shift
character said keep in mind the
whistleblower doesn't have any
first-hand knowledge of the event right
there's it's just not someone said that
Donald Trump Dam something somebody said
something then he went to ship and ship
turned around and corroborated it
preemptively
what is he corroborating the complaint
didn't have any there was no first-hand
knowledge of it in the first place my
gosh someone said nothing I'm gonna go
on Twitter and and I'm gonna lay the
foundation right that this happened that
someone said something and then you'll
come out and then I'll tell them that I
didn't talk with you about it also I
mean I might kill myself right so here's
another example if he claimed that Trump
tried to get dirt from the Ukraine on
his political opponents that's kind of
at the crux of this right well here's
something else if we're talking and I
don't want to do the what about ISM
because I don't think this is a what
about ISM I don't think there's a direct
comparison I think that what Schiff has
done is far far worse let me explain and
a videographic evidence take that young
turks just google would you do it
so Schiff himself tried to get tried to
procure I'm trying to use more official
term nude pictures of President Trump
from the Ukrainians but here's the thing
the Ukrainians turned out to be Russian
pranksters they were comedians and they
they pulled the wool over his eyes okay
and what's the nature of the compromise
well there were pictures of naked Trump
when they were in Ukraine we got their
conversation by the phone where they're
discussed those compromising materials
we are ready to provide it to FBI so we
will try to work with the FBI to figure
out a lot of your staff how we can
obtain copies of those of course we will
provide you all our copies of all our
materials okay first off oh I guess
we'll just ignore the raging homoerotic
undertones right yeah you come after Ben
Shapiro because he said no what no one
has described Brett Kavanaugh as penis
which is kind of a trend now with rape
doesn't happen with Michael Jackson
having a Bill Cosby right there did you
hear chef all right well can you send me
can you send me the photo negatives I
got a reminds me when I would try and
scramble the satellite signal when I was
a kid and I couldn't actually afford it
to my parents room the next room it is
amazing to me he was trying to find my
nude pictures and by the way nude
pictures that's not even a scandal it's
just an embarrassing especially with
this president do you think he would
actually care he's like that's the best
body come on look at that I don't he
would turn it off by the way hit the
notification bell join my club if you
have an already $99 anyone 69 for
students Federer Nats of active military
in debt just check the page we do a new
segment every single day because as
you've seen content creator will be
easier if I were a pimp yes there on the
recommended feed yeah trending at the
top may be backhanding shift here's
another example here why I think he's
absolutely just a stunning I mean it's a
skill as to how pieceof should be he is
I don't know that the text of the FBI
agents or was a page and stroke they
were released yeah yeah okay so we
direct evidence of FBI agents saying
that they wouldn't let Trump get elected
because they had quote insurance
policies in case he did all right Gary
responded that the FBI heavily favored
Trump over Clinton here you go they were
very selective on what they released
there were multiple reports last year
that the
we I was heavily predisposed against
Hillary Clinton and in favor of Donald
Trump you know here's the thing he's not
necessarily wrong depending on who's
working there at the end yeah I think we
all assume there can be biased because
people human beings have biases right
right sure but when Trump does that when
he's uh Kobe's a hacker Muller listed
this is a witch-hunt they try to accuse
him of obstruction yeah for doing
exactly what Schiff is doing there
here's another example at Schiff
he's known this is something people know
he's known it's kind of his his rays own
dad for leaking repeatedly private info
to the press and then lying about it
CNN is running quotes from noon on about
my testimony
you know testimony testimony what's
going on in there press percent since
he's never met a camera he didn't love I
would bet a lot of money that it was him
are you heard though you got the point
now you want to respond are you sure he
you know he's been making this claim all
along just to be precise yes or no did
you leak any of the information from his
testimony no I don't leak well beg to
differ how do you get caught flat-footed
by Wolf's lowest score ever on celebrity
jeopardy with this specific clip maybe
we cannot prove that he's lying and he's
gonna say trust me
and here's something else I would love
to I defer to a half agent Irishman
listen during the mauler Investigation
shift he repeatedly claimed that he had
seen beyond circumstantial evidence that
Trump had colluded with Russia even
after Muller ruled that there was no
evidence of collusion people say if the
report didn't say no collusion well on a
second it just says there's no evidence
of it you can say that about anything
someone who gets off for any crime well
the fact that he wasn't convicted of
shoplifting doesn't mean that he didn't
do it but there's no evidence so he's
not guilty of it that's how society
works correct absolutely we have a legal
system and if there is no evidence and
you are not convicted it means you
didn't commit the crime in the eyes of
the law right that's exactly that's what
that's exactly why we have the system is
to be able to call balls and strikes
make it don't make it done and then move
along and here what I find hilarious is
the example that he has beyond circum
change 11 it's it's like it's like the
Beyond meet impossible burger right it's
like no it's not actually and this is
not actually evidence right you actually
have to have something and when he's
asked repeatedly and repeatedly
repeatedly he dances around well we
didn't actually talk to him and well we
didn't actually get direct evidence but
like we put if you put together the
different inferences and lies then it's
a story yes if you put here's what's
important if you put together different
inferences accusations and of course
keeping in the front of your mind at all
times that I am a piece of sh but I
think you will come to see this issue in
a new light here's actually a clip of
him doing just that all you have right
now is a circumstantial case actually no
Chuck I can tell you that the case is
more than that and also go into the
particulars were seeking more than
circumstantial evidence now so again I
think do you have seen direct evidence
of collusion I don't want to go into
specifics that is not circumstantial as
I've said along there's plenty of
evidence of collusion and corrupt
commingling of work between the Trump
campaign and the Russians oh good lord
I mean just by the way unless you think
we're editing him out of context he
never did provide specific you and
you're waiting for it don't hold your
breath
yeah google it a lot of people haven't
seen this it only trended in two hours
on Twitter and was gone and that it was
gone in my opinion as bad as it gets
it's as bad as anything I've ever seen
in the political arena when people talk
about the right and the left are
dividing us I go no no hall second let's
not do the equivalency here because have
you seems pretty shift he made us an
entire dialogue of trumps phone call
with the Ukrainian president I want you
to see him doing this here presenting
this as though it was fact he expresses
his interest in meeting with the
president and says his country wants to
acquire more weapons from us to defend
itself and what is the president's
response
well it reads like a classic organized
crime shakedown I hear what you want I
have a favor I won't mind you none of us
have and I'm gonna say this only seven
times so you better listen good I want
you to make up dirt on my political
opponent understand lots of it now I
know some of you are asking because I
get it it's it's difficult today and our
polarized society to know ok who's
exaggerating where are you stretching
because everyone does especially for
comedy we do this yeah so you're
wondering how much what percentage of
that if we were to put a number on it is
is accurate zero nothing nothing no no
none of that ever happened and here's
something that's so dishonest to when
you watch it he's reading it and at one
point he looks up and looks back down
and goes but though as though he missed
a word it he's reading for an official
transcript he may he tried to clearly
imply that this was an official
transcript and then when he was called
on it this was his response that was
parody my summary of the president's
call was meant to be at least part in
parody you know when Donald Trump talked
about people got all upset because he
would talk about changing libel laws
right and this was really just to try
and get media stand out we weren't happy
about it how is that not slander right
yeah per second he read it as though
with the transcript he tried to hire
meisinger people in understand it's
parody that's a whole new problem
implying like because Donald Trump's is
such crazy stuff that you thought it was
real when I made up stuff that Donald
Trump said that was crazy that never
really happened but I told you he said
crazy stuff and so you tend to believe
that this crazy stuff is crazy stuff he
would say but I'm just a piece of [ __ ]
it is remarkable to me that this was
allowed to go this is I think that is
worthy of being forcibly removed from
office
I really do to me that's just a
pertinent I don't mean violently no I
mean this guy should be forced to resign
in absolute shame I can't think of
anything that would person if I fake
news more than reading from a fake
transcript and by the way the reason
he's doing that is because he knows that
most people who are not hyper ly engaged
unlooked at people in this room are
often people who are watching this show
or reading in the comments section he
knows are gonna walk
by the TV screen see this and go oh my
god I can't believe our president did
that right I can't believe he said that
and they're not going to see the aside
where he says it was clearly a parody
just like you don't see the slander you
don't see the libel you do see it sir
that occurs on the front page and then
the apology the retraction is issued two
weeks later on page 8 yeah he knew
exactly what he was doing and by the way
just to go into Ukraine thing a little
bit Democrats they've repeatedly reached
out to foreign countries including the
Ukraine for Jordan Trump okay so at
worse at the absolute worst Schiff is
just accusing Trump of what he has done
himself only Donald Trump hasn't done it
his accusations are false the favor that
Trump asked for was investigating
foreign meddling in a u.s. election
specifically regards a company called
CrowdStrike not Biden as Schiff was
trying I don't want to say shift
suggests right no suggesting it's it's
direct statement what shift Singh is
actually true it wasn't that Schiff
suggested that these things were
happening
he made Express statements intended to
deceive the public about what was said
that is fraud right there that's what it
is it's not yet it's not what what he
said happen isn't true but it is true
that shift it's like the inception of
yeah exactly and by the way I thought we
cared a whole hell of a lot about fair
elections Russian meddling in our
elections we have to get to the bottom
of that that was the entire thing we
heard from day one of his campaign now
he asks about it happening in Ukraine
right and we're like oh you can't ask
afford that right and to be fair later
on in the call it was mentioned that you
know Biden shut down this prosecutor the
investigation of it yes it was it was a
minor point and here's something that I
think is important right there there's a
lot that we don't know and that's why we
try not to just offer nothing more than
than conjecture
because maybe some more info could come
out you know the people who stand firm
in their opinions when there's not
enough info sometimes they don't really
age very well but I do think it's
important to look at what we do know and
compare it with what they've said that
is verifiably false right for example we
know for sure that that was not a
transcript and he said it was parody we
know for sure that Schiff said Donald
Trump was withholding military aid
unless they unless they investigated
that or sorry fired the prosecutor
that's what they
but here's if you understand it Trump
never threatened that at all that was
even mentioned the Ukraine officials did
not know about the change in military
foreign aid until a month after the call
yeah so you can't know everything but
you can know what they've said that is
false and you can know certain facets of
the story that are true the things that
we know to be true they've already
proactively lied about right that's
important for people to think of that's
important for people to point out and I
don't want to get into the minutiae of
it because like I said Glenn Beck has a
special - plays TV whole thing about the
Ukraine live after this there anything
else you guys want to say about you
don't think it's to me they know exactly
what they're doing I don't want to
ascribe ulterior motives we've always
tried to do that in the show yeah or if
we do change my mind when we actually
have debates that we've had in the show
with with politicians with professors
you know with people who are who are
worthy adversaries I always try to
assume that they are being sincere but
this is a wrap this is an exception it's
I don't even want say it's a radical
exception he went up there and lied and
read from a transcript that didn't exist
and when he and when he was cold on it
said well you know what that was meant
to be parody well what did you think it
was well you know what I think most
people thought it was what you intended
it to be which was a lie that you wanted
to be accepted wholesale as truth I
don't I didn't say this with Hillary
clip people like into she needs to be
put in jail I never jumped on that train
I don't like Nancy Pelosi it's crazy to
me that she's the reasonable one in the
park we have when you have a OC shift
Bernie Sanders Pelosi or Thanksgiving if
Donald Trump went up right we're talking
about what would happen a Republican did
it okay let's do this little walk it
through this exercise here and here I
have Peter Schiff mirroring what the
whistleblower was going to say abut for
them odd Twitter even though there was
no first-hand knowledge and shift no
there was no first-hand knowledge he
said he was going to go out and lie and
fabricate a transcript for the world to
see they were saying can you believe
this president is lying he's been
removed from office only he'd be telling
the truth yeah exactly yeah that was
video evidence that is how insane this
has become it's not what about ISM it is
far worse ISM as it relates to piece of
if Adams shift I hope you enjoyed this
clip if you don't these are the ABCs of
me baby you can just click Next video
and put it in double speed of course
search doesn't necessarily work
subscriptions notifications don't
necessarily work just bookmark this page
chicken we do a new video every single
day except for Sunday and if you don't
want this content to disappear join one
club at Ladder with credit comm slash
Mudd Club it's only $69 if your student
header interactive military and if you
don't you know listen I I don't want to
say that your hellbound but it that
doesn't look good for you